must be cool and having siblings from  it's like exotic places it could have  been and if we weren't advertisements  for how progressive our parents were  [Music]  it's much hatred going around feels like  the world's falling apart  it feels like there's something outside  of me pushing me off balance because the  whole country is a mess right now you  remember your birth mom right don't  start looking behind you you may not  like what you find  but if I'm crazy  are you the next step in human evolution  does that want to know that  [Applause]  [Music]  and I just wanted my own thing but I've  made my peace being the boring white  chick in the family something is trying  to communicate with me where more might  be losing his money we can't just do  nothing I don't think it's an accident  I'm your psychiatrist right now is all  that ever exists  I just noticed there's three people of  color here in a white boy cookin I like  these odds future America right here  you  you